[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه أمر مدهش تمامًا ،
أعني حقيقة أنه معلم تاريخي
في زراعة أوريغون ،
أعني حقيقة أنه يمكننا أخذ خنزير معدل
وراثيًا
ووضعه في إنسان
وإنقاذ حياته شيء  التي حلمنا بها
منذ حوالي 25 عامًا ، قمنا بتعديل 10
جينات في هذا القلب الكبير ،
تم القضاء على أربعة جينات
ثلاثة منها مسؤولة عن إنتاج
الأجسام المضادة التي تسبب الرفض ، لذلك
تم القضاء على هذه الجينات الثلاثة
ثم تم إخراج جين واحد
للتحكم في  نمو الخنزير وأعضائه ،
لم نقم بهذا أبدًا في
الإنسان وأحب أن أعتقد
أننا قدمنا له خيارًا أفضل مم
كان يمكن أن يكون عليه استمرار علاجه ول
ن ما إذا كان يومًا أسبوعًا وشهرًا وسنة لا
عرف  ما يريده الجميع حقًا
هو
ألا يقتصر الأمر ببساطة على
إمداد الأعضاء البشرية
للزراعة وأنت تعلم أن عددًا من
الأعضاء يمكن علاجها أه تعرفها واستخدامها
بهذه الطريقة
من حيوان ويمكن الوصول إليها  يتم تسويقه
كدواء إذا كان هذا
صحيحًا ، فسنغير وجه
ما هو ممكن
للأشخاص الذين ينتظرون الآن سنوات
لإجراء عملية زرع قلب
[موسيقى]